“We were somewhere around Barstow, on the
edge of the desert, when the drugs began to
take hold.”
This is the opening line from the highly acclaimed
roman à clef Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas:
A Savage Journey to the Heart of the American
Dream written by Hunter S. Thompson, one of
America’s most countercultural and anti-authoritarian
writers.
The untamed master of his own self-titled
genre, “gonzo journalism,” Thompson set
ablaze the American standards for journalism
during the 1960s and 70s with a cornucopia
of drugs, alcohol, gun toting, and most notably,
his exemplary writing.
Hunter Stockton Thompson was born in Louisville,
Kentucky on July 18, 1937, to Virginia Ray
Davison, a local librarian, and Jack Robert
Thompson, an insurance agent and World War
I veteran.
Thompson’s father, however, suffered from
myasthenia gravis, a debilitating neuromuscular
disease, and passed away when Thompson was
just fourteen years of age.
After the loss, Virginia Thompson delved into
heavy alcoholism and Hunter followed suit.
Beyond heavy drinking, during his senior year
of high school, Thompson was arrested as an
accessory to an armed robbery and was sentenced
to sixty days in the Kentucky Jefferson county
jail.
While imprisoned, the superintendent of his
high school denied him permission to take
his final examinations, and subsequently,
Thompson failed to graduate.
Thompson received an early release on the
condition that he would join the United States
Air Force.
Before leaving Kentucky, he purchased a case
of beer and spitefully threw each bottle one
by one through the windows of the superintendent’s
house.
After being initially rejected by the Air
Force’s aviation program, Thompson transferred
to Eglin Air Force Base in the Florida panhandle
in 1956 where he was reassigned to electronics.
Shortly after, he began paving the way for
his future journalism career by attending
night classes at Florida State University.
As a former sports enthusiast, Thompson also
talked his way into a sports editor position
for The Command Courier, the base’s onsite
publication, after fabricating stories about
his prior experience in the field.
In an interview with The Paris Review by Douglas
Brinkley and Terry McDonell, Thompson describes
how he learned the fundamentals of journalism:
“I went to the base library and found three
books on journalism.
I stayed there reading them until it closed.
Basic journalism.
I learned about headlines, leads: who, when,
what, where, that sort of thing.
I barely slept that night.
This was my ticket to ride, my ticket to get
out of that damn place.”
Despite the military’s policy about employment
off campus, Thompson defied protocol and began
writing for a local paper called The Playground
News in Fort Walton Beach, Florida.
To quote Thompson, “I’d put things in
the local paper that I couldn’t put in the
base paper.
Really inflammatory shit.
The Air Force got very angry about it.
I was constantly doing things that violated
regulations.”
In one instance, Thompson wrote about Arthur
Godfrey, a popular radio broadcaster who had
been invited to the base for a firepower demonstration,
but instead Thompson covered how Godfrey had
been previously caught illegally shooting
animals from the air in Alaska: “The base
commander told me: ‘Goddamn it, son, why
did you have to write about Arthur Godfrey
that way?’”
After multiple instances of insubordination,
now a recurrent theme for Thompson, it was
no surprise that in 1957 his commanding officer,
Col. William S. Evans, discharged him early.
What was a surprise was that it was an honorable
discharge.
To quote Col. Evans concerning the discharge,
“In summary, this airman, although talented,
will not be guided by policy.”
Although there were no beer bottles thrown
in the direction of the colonel, or jet fuel
leaked from the airplanes and set ablaze,
Thompson did concoct a fictionalized press
release that was actually published in The
Command Courier through which his comedic
hyperbole shines.
He writes, “An apparently uncontrollable
iconoclast, Thompson was discharged today
after one of the most hectic and unusual Air
Force careers in recent history.”
In 1959, Thompson relocated to New York City
where he audited courses at Columbia University.
He acquired a position as a copy boy for Time
where he took in $51 a week in wages (about
$408 today).
However, it wasn’t long before he was fired
for insubordination.
Shortly after, he began reporting for The
Middletown Daily Record in Middletown, New
York, but his employment didn’t last long
there either; he was fired for destroying
an office candy machine and arguing with a
local restaurant owner who happened to be
the paper’s main advertiser.
In 1961, Thompson began a peregrination across
the country.
He settled down in Big Sur, California to
work on two novels, Prince Jellyfish and The
Rum Diary (the latter remained untouched until
rediscovered by actor Johnny Depp who had
been living in Thompson’s basement.
Depp encouraged Thompson to revisit the novel
and it was finally published in 1998).
During the same year, a group of religious
cultists founded their institution near his
property.
To try to get rid of them, Thompson fastened
the head of a wild boar to the group’s front
door and hung the entrails around the rear
view mirror of one of the member’s vehicles.
In 1962, Thompson served as a correspondent
in South America for The National Observer,
formerly a Dow Jones-owned weekly publication,
as well as reported for the Brazil Herald
in Rio de Janeiro, the nation’s sole English-written
publication.
While there, Thompson had acquired, for unknown
reasons, a pet monkey.
Tragically, the monkey died after reportedly
leaping, or at least falling, off the hotel
balcony where Thompson was staying.
(See: Do Non-Human Animals Commit Suicide?)
It is unclear whether the monkey had an alcohol
issue prior to the unofficial adoption.
However, it would seem the monkey did partake
from Thompson’s stash.
Friend and travel author Robert W. Bone commented
by saying, “Everyone figured the monkey,
being an alcoholic, had the DTs (Delirium
Tremens).”
After leaving Brazil in 1964, Thompson returned
to California where he continued to work for
the National Observer and was assigned to
examine the suicide of Ernest Hemingway in
Ketchum, Idaho.
During his investigation, Thompson stole a
pair of elk antlers that hung above Hemingway’s
door seeing them as a ceremonious and posthumous
bequeathal.
However, even his stay with the National Observer
was short-lived.
After a disagreement with his editor, who
had refused to publish Thompson’s review
on Tom Wolfe’s The Kandy-Kolored Tangerine-Flake
Streamline Baby, Thompson quit and moved to
San Francisco to work for The Spyder, an alternative
and underground Berkeley paper, submerging
himself into the pervasive drug and hippie
lifestyle.
At this point, The Nation hired Thompson to
cover the outlaw motorcycle gang Hell’s
Angels, who had permeated the California scene
in the 1950s and 1960s.
After the article, The Motorcycle Gangs: Losers
and Outsiders, was published in 1965 and began
reaping vast attention, Thompson began riding,
partying, and living among the notorious group,
gathering information for his soon-to-be-hit
Hell’s Angels: A Strange and Terrible Saga.
Thompson made no secret of the fact that he
was a journalist working on a book featuring
the Angels while he was with them, something
they surprisingly didn’t mind, and even
were quite open with him.
However, at one point, the gang severely beat
Thompson.
There are conflicting accounts as to why this
happened, but the general story is that it
had something to do with a comment made by
Thompson about Hell’s Angel “Junkie George.”
Junkie was beating his wife, and Thompson
reportedly stated of this, “Only a punk
beats his wife,” drawing the ire of the
Angels around at the time, who he later stated
were none of the ones he was close to.
The publication in 1966 was the beginning
of Thompson’s personal and immersive dive
into finding his voice within journalism.
He discarded all the detached and unbiased
journalistic conventions and instead explored
his own baptismal plunge into a world of contrarianism,
with himself as the central figure.
This style later became known as gonzo journalism.
More specifically, Thompson stated that gonzo
journalism is a style of reporting that bases
itself on William Faulkner’s idea “that
the best fiction is far more true than any
kind of journalism and the best journalists
have always know this.”
In 1970, he wrote The Kentucky Derby is Decadent
and Depraved, an article published by Scanlan’s
Monthly magazine.
Although some critics claim that Hell’s
Angels signified the start of his gonzo journalism,
the Kentucky Derby piece is generally considered
more representative of the style.
However, according to Thompson, Hell’s Angels
was the instrumental key to his calling as
a vagabond and pioneer journalist: “Hell’s
Angels all of a sudden proved to me that,
Holy Jesus, maybe I can do this.”
As to the name of this offshoot of the 1960s
“New Journalism” trend, this is credited
to the then editor of the Boston Globe Sunday
Magazine, Bill Cardoso, who wrote to Thompson
concerning the Kentucky Derby piece stating,
“This is it, this is pure Gonzo.
If this is a start, keep rolling.”
Thompson liked the word as a name for this
style of journalism and adopted it.
As to how Cardoso came up with it, it has
been variously stated it was slang for the
“last man standing” among a group of binge
drinkers; that it was slang for “bizarre”;
or that it was borrowed from the 1960 song
by James Booker, “Gonzo.”
Whatever the origin of the name, Thompson
himself first used it in his most notable
work, Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas, a story
which he sarcastically quipped is “a vile
epitaph for the Drug Culture of the Sixties.”
This drug-addled and psychotic adventure during
the uprising of drug criminalization first
appeared as a series in Rolling Stone in 1971
and then became a published book in 1972.
Thompson was inspired to write the book while
he was on assignment for Sports Illustrated
to write a 250-word caption for the Mint 400,
a desert off-road race in Las Vegas.
Thompson himself concluded that the book was
a failure, but not in terms of success or
abhorrence towards his own work, but a failure
in that his initial goal was to script the
entire Vegas journey in one unedited notebook
and publish it.
This, he states, would have been true gonzo
journalism.
In retrospect, Thompson acknowledged that
in order to have achieved his goal he would
have had to be the director, producer, cameraman,
and lead actor all at the same time to pull
off his story correctly.
Instead, he reworked the piece, taking liberties
to create scenes where he had been heavily
intoxicated, as well as precautions to protect
the identities of certain individuals for
their security.
He also played around with the chronology
of certain events, changing a month’s time
to a mere few days.
Towards the end of his career and life, Thompson
resided at Owl Farm, his compound in Woody
Creek, Colorado.
After writing several other successful books
such as Fear and Loathing on the Campaign
Trail ’72 and covering other political and
social issue stories, Thompson came full circle
as a writer, working for ESPN covering sports
in his typical frenetic, poetic style starting
in 2000.
This all ended in February of 2005 when Thompson
shot himself in the head in his home at Owl
Farm.
While some conspiracy theorists contend he
was actually killed due to, at the time, working
on a piece on the terrorist attacks on 9/11,
it should be noted that his grandson and daughter-in-law
were in the room next to him when he died
and reported nothing suspicious leading up
to the suicide.
He was also talking on the phone to his wife,
Anita, a mere few seconds before he shot himself.
She even heard him cock the gun, but assumed
the sound she heard was him hitting a typewriter
key- getting back to work after he set the
phone down, so she hung up.
A note written by Thompson served as something
of a suicide letter.
He inscribed, “No More Games.
No More Bombs.
No More Walking.
No More Fun.
No More Swimming.
67.
That is 17 years past 50.
17 more than I needed or wanted.
Boring.
I am always bitchy.
No Fun — for anybody.
67.
You are getting Greedy.
Act your (old) age.
Relax — This won’t hurt.”
On August 20, 2005, a private funeral was
arranged for all of Thompson’s closest friends
and family.
His ashes were fired from a cannon on top
of a 153-foot tower to the music of Norman
Greenbaum’s “Spirit in the Sky” and
Bob Dylan’s “Mr. Tambourine Man.”
The sendoff was accompanied by a great display
of fireworks and completely funded by Johnny
Depp who previously portrayed Thompson in
the screen adaption of Fear and Loathing in
Las Vegas, and, later in 2011, The
Rum Diary.